all right this tournament is starting
how does this work well
it's fisher random so that back
row of pieces will be randomized
there are some rules
with how they are organized exactly on
the back rank it's been a while
since i played in a fishery random
tournament
i will be playing how many rounds
probably five right
five round tournament
fischer random okay three minute chess
and wow this is very close to being
similar to a regular position the
knights are in at their same home my
opponent wants to draw
no way
i'm here to play
i'm here to play i want to get this in
this is this is regular chess and get
all my pieces out
let me go one square here
all right b4 b5
push that knight around
get out of there
get out of there my bishop needs to move
and my queen needs to move in order to
get castled
opposite their king maybe one day
they'll be a tactic
very long castling
pawn push i
i'm assuming
a4 i'll just keep throwing my pawns down
see if they could induce some weaknesses
a little pond staircase here
get out of there
get out of there
okay let's let's retreat my you know
what peace could do um better my dark
square bishop he's a big dummy let's get
opposite their queen
probably a bit scared seeing that
see they were
all right i need to trade a little bit
my bishop not trade but my bishop still
needs some more work
all right he's working
this is um something i have to be a
little bit concerned about
more pressure could be placed on it
right let's get this in no i'm just i'm
dropping material now
maybe there's some tricks though
might be some tricks
with um
let's take here
tempo my knight wants to be where
let's take like this
pawn takes
okay here i finally have a plan i there
without any captures on the board it was
tough to
come up with something great and why
wasn't i seeing that there might be some
sacrifice here
i should have been considering that like
yesterday
bishop checks okay my knight wants to
get here i want to get rid of the dark
square bishops and jump in actually
knight here right away might even be
best the queen is kind of stuck
no
no no no no
let's take that
knight here if there's a pawn push i
don't want to take because well maybe
maybe i could consider that i like my
i like my knight let's get off of the
same diagonal as that bishop
this is a very slow game tricky stuff
against my queen then i was ready to
move and give check i need to defend my
my queen i'll go for the exchange and
then advance
i get some play if this pawn pushes now
my knight wants to be here
right here
oh okay
big decision
i don't want to lock everything up
i don't want to lock everything up i
want to get play on the queen side
somehow my night belongs here
i think
i want to get rid of him as soon as
possible
my night belongs here
back rank issues there might be for my
opponent
come on move
very tight game right now
so so much for the good knight versus
bad bishop if my opponent takes here
whichever way i have to recapture but i
guess
now i have
if there is an advantage i have it in
the form of what i have it in the form
of king safety and now i could actually
hit at this
b2 point
so this pawn is actually
playing a role i have my
back rank okay
and
let's give a check
if they take now this is going to be
winning so i get to pin
and then finally escort my pawn there
to b8
all right they resign this is not a war
zone
so we have to wait to see how
everything else happened in that first
round
this is
five rounds
six players so that is five rounds
and there are some other
players going at it
these guys
these two i will be playing against
and two others black way down on time
and okay i was thinking that was mate
but black head check
11 seconds
11 seconds
well eight seconds for black down now on
time and position
get the king to c3 pick up the pawn
run
okay
up a ton of material
keep pushing
sneak in pick your favorite way to do it
point five seconds the game is just not
going to end
white won that game
okay
and this game is over as well
all right so round two coming up here we
go
whoa what do we do with this
this pawn is hit
let's stop that what's unprotected that
was unprotected
okay my knight belongs here
this pawn i want to get moving
now let's do this first get some control
over the center
and
bishop here pawn push
again i want i want my bishop to not get
shut out of the game
maybe there's some tactics against the
queen if pawn takes or push
i was going to blunder my bishop just
then
let's come back right here stay
developed
there's still meant to be some trick
with pawn push and the knight moving
maybe i should address that with this
move
this is a very
weird uh
position already okay now there's
finally some clarification in the center
so i'm going to jump in here and follow
suit with this knight
and i want to show that he's a bad
bishop no he actually he'll spring to
life so i could focus on the e4 square
that much
that much i'm aware of and now i can
maybe invade along the light squares
there is no castling now for my opponent
i want to get on light squares
whoa
um
let's take here have this half opened
get my knight on this square i need to
get castled king side or queen side i'm
thinking
king side
get here with tempo
thinking about b5 i'm thinking about
maybe first d6 and then b5
now i'm much more inclined to do this
move
now let's do that right now as otherwise
maybe there's a push and the knight
could
take up a post on c6
let's go in here with tempo actually now
let's strike here right now there is no
pawn push successfully actually this
pawn is pinned as soon as white castle
this this pawn is immobile from
capturing in this direction or moving
forward
i don't know that there's a good way to
meet this threat
so i'm not castle just yet but i want to
exploit this pin now there's two pins
there is no recapture this knight has to
find a new home
and i'm just winning a piece now
i'm winning a piece and i'm going to
whoa
i'm going to
almost lose my queen
no
let's just play here
my opponent recaptures
and then i castle
that's the plan so
i'm up a piece i just want to trade
let's just trade
let's just trade
no if i captured those two pawns right
there are too much
i don't want to allow that
now i have control on this file
i don't think it really matters how i
recapture if there's this capture i'll
probably go like this so i don't have to
babysit a pawn on d5
less than 45 seconds i actually have a
time edge
let's watch over light squares so the
queen isn't going to do anything my
bishop could do something much better
much better their bishop is actually
stuck
i'm going to try and keep him stuck
there's no way for their bishop to get
active
except that way
my
king needs to do something
he needs to do something actually what's
stopping me from going after this pond
let's take him
and then get right back here
this is
kind of tricky to win
kind of
tricky now it's not though
their bishop is kind of stuck
kind of stuck
okay now my knight
cleanest way to do it i believe is in
this direction
stop this advance and you stop
everything that y could possibly do
there he's not going anywhere everything
else is immobile and these pawns just
drop off one by one
just watch out for stalemate
it's not gonna happen though i don't
think no stalemate
there we go
all right
gg
that's round two
of fischer random chess 916 let's close
out and see what's going on elsewhere
still these two guys here
oh these two games excuse me
um actually i didn't look at the
standings i'll have to maybe look right
after this game how's white doing white
seems to be
oh what an interesting end game here
very interesting end game if rook takes
king here i think white is actually
these pawns are far enough advance where
white could have captured the rook and
then it escorted those connected past
central pawns
still a very close battle though this
pawn is past
doesn't get much tighter there with the
the clocks
upon push there's a check you block
right here this past b-pawn is dangerous
rook takes pawn
oh that was missed
king here
rick takes pawn
rook takes pawn
it's the only try rook takes pawn
whoa what a resource
very good move to be seeing with very
little time on the board and this is oh
that's helping the black king out
king needs to get closer but it's not so
easy to do that this is going to come
down to the clock who can move their
mouse quicker less than seven seconds
each
time burner time
who cares about position you have to
throw in checks
two seconds for black
oh it's not working out for black
no time white wins
oh man
it's a tough game okay they're all
finished what are the standings
okay i can't look at them now okay um
what do we do in this position let's
start out with this
i usually invest so much more time in
the beginning but
i don't want to this time i want to
let's get all my pieces out here
all my pieces out
um
let's keep it closed
okay this is a good spot for my knight i
think actually he's going to jump in
here
it's a little bit now he's not
let's stop this advance oh my goodness
oh
i thought that was close to me i thought
i might be needing to block with my
queen
fortunately my knight was on e1
oh that could have been bad
that good and bad i was thinking for a
second about playing g4
but i think simply castling
and then playing f4 f5 is going to be my
plan this is my furthest advanced pond
so i want to get another one up right
next to them
cubit sized
castle
okay i have to watch out for a fork
uh
i'm gonna defend like this because
knight here to here is going to come and
i don't i was going to play to d2 but
knight a3 to c4 would then come with
temple with my queen on d2
so i can't really stop the knight from
getting here i do have this i want to
get my king off of this diagonal for
sure
but this is a big weakness
big weakness
now i could actually regroup all right
oh my goodness i dropped that pawn
okay hang on take with my queen
he was a dead piece anyway wasn't he who
needed that pawn at c he was backward as
they come
right
who needs that c pawn he wasn't playing
a c4 i didn't even need to defend that
pawn
didn't i see my knight was here let's
get f4 f5 in i have enough support for
this still
gotta go forward with it
okay now there's a serious serious
problem
against that black king f6
i insist
double up on the f-file
get my knight on h5 remove him and i
think the game is over
can i remove him
f6 i guess f6 maybe i do this
let's get all my pieces working bishop
here to here bishop here bishop h6
bishop bishop h6 it might be knight
check and then queen recaptures but no
there would be pawn takes the pound
would be in my rook and if i took the
bishop could recapture
let's come over here though what's wrong
with piling up on h7
change of plans
rook here and then eventual sack pawn
push i take a couple times rook up and
over
seems very appealing
very appealing
oh actually
i'm very tempted to do that
let's go for it
hang on there might be something better
yes
this move right here
yeah i like this move right here
just attack the pinned piece and now
night here to here i think
because otherwise there's going to be
mate happening soon
oh they gave that up okay
this is still hit though
and now
put pressure on this
i want to get my bishop right here
it's not so easy though the rook's gonna
come over my knight is way out of play
if i take this pawn this knight has some
trouble there's queen check here as well
oh this would work actually
queen check
let's take here first 28 seconds
queen check no
just not here
attack the pin piece
if rook here i would have queen check
and then knight takes pawn
which would be mate so if rook played
there earlier queen f5 the rook would
have to block then i take the rook pawn
recaptures then i take the knight on e6
this king is now
running for his life and that's actually
mate all right
good game let's close out of that
round three is finished and
scoreboard i have two out of my first
two
and
let's see the other games that are going
on with
round three
whoa serious time advantage for white
interesting position for black though
rook check
rook check king here
rook check king here oh this pawn is
just dropping
there's no time now this guy flies
i'm pretty sure i've played him before
and
oh yeah i have lost against him i think
in these 960 games i might be playing
him
next round or the last
we're gonna see
33 seconds to six seconds
whoa
black could win this
black could definitely win this black is
black is going to get another queen no
time is even coming off the clock
whoa
watch out for stalemate 2.8 seconds
it's may black actually won that
whoa what a comeback
nice
okay all games are complete
all games are complete
here we go this guy apparently moves
fast
already move he moves fast okay so let
me try and move fast as well this is
going to be tough to organize our pieces
it's going to be tough to organize our
pieces i want my knight on f3
alright let's get him there
if i do this there's pawn push
my queen how do i get my queen working
let's do this
let's grab some space
which direction do i want to castle
i don't even know
um
i think he could be very cramping
actually knight here is
so dangerous
my queen has to watch over the f2 square
not fun at all i need to get rid of this
knight as soon as possible
he's having none of it
none of it let's post up here so then i
could do this and then this
that's my plan
whoa did they try to castle oh no i was
threatening something dangerous
i should have connected my knight sooner
okay this bishop is a monster
my knight wants to be here with checked
it's close to mate or something
very close to me
night checks here
let's just drop all the way back
all the way back
pawn push here i i need a castle
i need to castle here night check is
there they have to be really scared
let's open stuff up their queen is
caught in the corner
i moved my bishop and they castled where
does he belong
give a night check
do i even want a castle in that
direction i could go kingside let's work
on this side of the board their queen is
stuck
now she's being rescued
let's watch over these central squares
pawn push i have night here
i think this works because i have enough
to attack on this square now
i'm on this as well after the sun
if knight takes take with the pawn no
the bishop
it's with check they're probably gonna
sack
rook takes to take the knight now ah now
i do
just up a piece
and play queen g7 next
or this
i'm okay with trades pawn advance my
bishop cannot be touched
um yeah let's just open this up if they
if they're gonna sack now they're gonna
be down a full rook
actually i could have this move as well
getting more material
more material
it's close to me
very close to me
bishop is in trouble bishop moves it's
made on c7
he resigned
all right good game last round coming up
round
five
last round here
in this sit and go tournament
um
let's see these guys
let's see these guys
all right fischer random it's been a
long while since i played fisher random
it's a lot of fun
i think it uh helps out with your
calculation
skills
forces you to think right from move one
there's none of this uh
opening theory stuff throw out all of
your opening theory books
good position for this bishop not so
great position for this knight he's seen
better days as well both knights not
doing so much the bishops are
he's very well placed
black better make sure this f5 advance
cannot be played successfully
material count three
seven puns versus seven
okay the queens are coming off
you control f5 how does white advance
here
hmm
something like
a5 a4
this rook is going to get active oh
nice shot exploiting the pin on this
queen
now black is
definitely the better side
this is
a permanent home for the bishop
the knight probably
should have taken
and then pounced down this square this
bishop could turn out to simply be out
of play
unless a rook could somehow get to e7 24
seconds for white
to 39
okay
even like this there we go
night coming in very strong now pawn
pushes
checks
more checks
check here king here pawn push
pawn push with check
here we go the bishop comes to life
pawn knight
pawn knight bishop and rook are all
working
ship here
oh tricky nights there
oh it wasn't taken
you've taken the knight first and then
this
11 seconds for white
quite balanced here
wise
whoever's faster is going to win
uh-oh
uh-oh
black is not moving fast enough
neither is white
i went to the corner
he went to the corner four seconds
two seconds to three
one second to two
time burners where the time burners
they're flying one second to point one
one second to zero
white wins
oh man
all right
all right
so that's all the games okay last round
coming up i'm trying to go five for five
five for five team black
how do you deal with this arrangement
okay i think i want my
queen to see but not so fast
let's get this working
i want to do
similar get my bishop working oh man i'm
in trouble i'm in big trouble you know
why
you know why
how do you defend this pawn
right here
my opponent had the same thing right
here to here
uh oh they could do the same thing
our knights are gonna go into pac-man
mode gobble gobble
back here gobble maybe
knight g5 you can return the favor
that's that's pretty impressive isn't it
yeah i know
you're going after my queen smothered
mate of the queen
who would have thunk it
who would have thunk it all right i'm
gonna take your queen
see how you like it
okay now i'm gonna run away
this is a symmetrical position but i
have a leading development don't i how
did that happen
oh no they have this pawn here
that's kind of insignificant my knight
this is like the in-betweener variation
this is the in-betweener variation and
now we see the difference between having
a pawn here
only at this point right here do we see
the difference i get to move again and
capture
whoa
how cool was this variation
now i'll take here and now we have this
now
get your night out
the invert in-betweener variation
okay this is the only open file we need
to get there
let's get these guys going
king position
king position is where it's at i was
almost ready to uh blunder upon with e5
you've gone far enough pawn
i don't want to deal with you getting to
a5 and then i have to wonder
i have to wonder about
is the a file gonna open up
pawn push now allows this knight to play
here
nope
maybe i can get this in f5 and then this
um
end game position where i'm up upon
okay
let me make one more preventative move i
don't want this knight to play here i
want to be able to move my knight
but he needs to watch over this square
if i do this takes takes there is this
knight check available but i think i
could just get out of the way
and then he has to move
hang on
let's try it
minute 23.
maybe i could take with the king
avoid all that tricky stuff
yeah let's avoid the tricky stuff
the knight moves here
because then there'll be king here rook
takes first if i take with the knight
the knight plays to e5 if i take with
the rook the knight takes the pawn
and now i have
a majority in the center
let's get him rolling
both of us do well to keep the tension
with the rooks this is the only
completely open file so
maintaining control over it is number
one these knights offset each other
when you focus on h4 and f4
less than 55 for my opponent
he has passed so i could play here with
check
let's sneak my king over a little bit a
little bit more central
pawn push gonna be played
to break up these guys they're strong
they're strong when they sit side by
side like this this is a very good king
position and i need to
get rid of it
i need to get rid of that king position
very soon actually the knight was ready
to play here
and then jump into this square because i
was in a pin
35 seconds
the idea here i just want to give check
to the king as soon as i do that i think
white is going to be in some serious
trouble
right here to hear is the idea
knight f5 or even actually g3 the more
aggressive square
less than 20 seconds
knight f5 to e6 okay now i have an
active rook versus their passive rook
still want to do this
knight here i take the pawn with check
and then the knight
knight here it's mate
that's a cool mate
all right
good games good games let's close out of
that
there's some games still finishing up
right now
last game
the very last game and that one is
finished as well alright
black ended up winning that one there
first place confetti in the cube
or excuse me the crown stars
five three three three one
zero
alrighty
the game is all to those who jumped in
in this sit and go tournament
you